so I I don't need to introdu myself
again and can you see my
screen yes
good here we are so you get to hear from
me about a lot of
math I hope everyone is very excited
about
this so I will tell you about
two different training objectives for G
flow Nets you heard about flow matching
and how optimizing a flow matching
objective at every state in a jlow net
leads to getting a policy which can
sample objects in proportion to their
reward and I will motivate and introduce
two new objectives called detail balance
and trajectory balance which are the
ones that we most often use in practice
in applications of gonets and I'll
conclude with some discussion of of how
to train how to train your
gonet now um just to review and to set
up um set up background unfortunately my
figure is not
animated but this is the kind of figure
that we just saw in emanuel's talk we
have a direct directed a cyclic graph
which specifies the structure of a
generative process we have an initial
State here labeled as zero and and we
can follow the edges in the picture from
left to right until we reach a terminal
state which is marked with a
square we think of we think of the
terminal objects as representing
completed terminal States as
representing completed objects like the
molecules or smiley faces that we're
trying to
generate and we learned in the last talk
that when we assign a number to every
Edge a flow we can extract from this
flow a policy which is just as in RL a
way
of getting a distribution over
subsequent States when we're sitting at
a particular
State the way we turn a flow into a
policy is by taking the flows to all of
the children of the state we're at and
dividing by the sum in other words
normalizing to get a probability
distribution so for instance we may be
at s0o so we look at a flow to S1 and to
s 2 and we our policy goes to S1 or to
S2 in proportion with probability
proportional to the flow to S1 and to S2
and so on until reaching a terminal
State what we're trying to achieve
through any G flate training procedure
is to make the marginal likelihood that
the policy will terminate in a
given completed object proportional to
its
reward and the main result that we that
we covered that Emanuel covered in the
last talk is that when we enforce a
local condition that at every state the
flow in equals the flow out the policy
that's obtained from this flow happens
to sample proportionally to the
reward this is the first main theorem of
jlet that if flow matching is satisfied
at every state inside the state space
then the corresponding policy sample in
proportion to their
reward so nothing new so
far but there are some problems with
this objective which Emanuel already
alluded to so let's go through those um
the first one is that it's a local
objective that is the objective at a
particular State depends only on the
flows into and out of that state not
other ones in other parts of the state
space now when we perform an update at
one state we still might affect the edge
flows somewhere far away and that's due
to the neural net parameterization of
flows so the flow function is given to
us by a neural network and so we change
the parameters when we update the edge
flow in one part of the graph so it
might affect the edge in another part of
the graph this is important for
generalization on the other hand this
locality still has a
limitation and this limitation is
something that happens in other
reinforcement settings as well and it's
the problem of slow credit
assignment I can illustrate it with this
figure so imagine that so our graph is
going top down here so imagine that we
sampled our policy and we saw a very
high reward State this x at the
bottom and the flows on the edges along
this trajectory were very small so what
will happen which Edge flows will get
updated when I got this very high reward
State
well the flow matching might be very
close to satisfied that all of the all
of the states in the beginning of the
trajectory where their flows are small
so the only place where there there's a
discrepancy would be at the very end
where the inflow is small but we got a
high reward so I should increase the
edge flow there so the only update
happens near the end so now this um this
Edge there
now gets a higher gets a higher flow
through a gradient update so now what
has to happen to propagate this
information about a high reward state
closer to the beginning of the graph
well we have to see this previous
state and so until I see that state
again I won't get any update so imagine
I saw this state again now the outflow
is high now but the inflow is still
small so now that one has to be updated
and the signal is propagated one step
closer to the initial state and so on
and if trajectories are long and the
likelihood of reaching these states is
small it can take a very long time to
get an update to flows or policies near
the beginning of the trajectory when we
H have um a an interesting State at the
end this is the problem of slow credit
assignment and it's a major limitation
of gfets with local training
objectives now another problem with
matching which Emanuel also mentioned is
the possibly High computation
cost we we usually when we train models
with FL matching we have a model which
takes in a state and outputs
simultaneously The Edge flows to all of
the subsequent all of the children of
that state in the single neural network
usually actually the model is outputting
the logs of those States but that's not
what's important here um so flow
matching is trying to enforce that in
flow equals outflow and Computing the
outflow is easy in this green rectangle
we just have to evaluate our neural net
and sum all of the edge flows that it
outputs the flows to all the children
but Computing the inflow is not so easy
because we would have to evaluate our
model at all the parents of the state of
Interest so if there are n parents then
to compute the flow matching loss we
need n plus one neural net evaluations
to compute the loss and for problems
with many parents for any given State
this can be
prohibitive so that that's a problem we
want to avoid
that and this um the this this
observation is what motivated the
introduction of the first loss that's
not flow matching called detail
balance so I will introduce this one
next so the idea of detailed balance is
that instead of working with Edge flows
we'll introduce a different
parameterization so we will directly
learn the policy the the policy which is
a distribution over children of every
state in the graph it's just like in R
person learning it's output by a model
which takes a state as input and gives
us the logits of all of the possible
actions all of the possible
children and in addition to the policy
we need some auxiliary
objects so I explain them in reverse
order so the we need a special object
called a backward policy and I'll talk a
little more about what it actually means
in a while but you should think of it as
a policy which can start at a terminal
State and Sample backward until getting
to an initial state so it's a
distribution or a model that gives a
distribution over the parents of any
state in the
graph and this looks a little funny
because why would we ever want to start
at a terminal State and Sample backwards
get a trajectory that leads there but
this can actually be useful as I'll talk
about near the end and in addition to
those we learn a single single estimator
a neural net that gives us one number
scalar for every state called the state
flow and you should think of this as so
when flow matching is satisfied then
flow in equals flow out and they're both
equal to something called the state flow
it's the amount flowing amount of water
flowing through the
state now how is um how is this
parameterization related to the one used
in flow matching so if we look
at if we look at the forward policy and
how it's defined in terms of the flow so
this bottom left here um the likelihood
of passing to a child V from a state s
is proportional to the flow from s to V
so it's the flow on the edge s Tov
divided by the sum of all the flows
coming
out um and similarly the backward policy
can be defined in terms of a flow so
instead of normalizing over all of the
children we normalize all the over all
the parents so to decide which parent to
transition to the backward policy takes
the flow to all the parents and
normalizes to get a distribution summing
to
one um so if we look at these two
equations um we see that there are two
different ways to express the state flow
just via
algebra the state flow is on the one
hand the outflow of the parent times the
forward policy the likelihood so the
outflow at s times the likelihood of
transitioning from s to S Prime and on
the other hand it's the inflow at S
Prime Times the backward likelihood so
the the backward policy is probability
of transitioning from S Prime to
S
so the the key part here is the equality
of these two ways of writing the edge
flow
we can visualize it also on the picture
on the right where these two quantities
inflow at inflow at S Prime Times
backward policy or outflow at s times
forward policy are both supposed to be
equal to the flow on the Edge from s to
S
Prime so now um some magic happens and
we turn this equality into a training
objective so remember that we're
learning f and the backward policy PB
and the policy PF so we take this
quality and make it a constraint that we
try to
enforce so the detail balance objective
for an edge from s to S Prime is trying
to make these two quantities equal so
this is just like the flow matching
constraint inflow equals outflow is
turned into objective log of inflow
divided by outflow squared we do the
same thing
here and just like um just like in flow
matching this
um we can stabilize this by adding small
smoothing constants to numerator and
denominator and um let's take a closer
look at this
last so first of
all this is written as a log of some
products and quotients but because we're
outputting Flows In The Log domain and
because we're outputting our policies
through their log
logits we can do some algebra and turn
this into just a sum of logs squared so
it was just a quadratic loss in terms of
the logits and the state
FL and um let's also think about what
happens at the terminal States at the
terminal States we know that the inflow
is supposed to equal the reward and with
the detailed balance loss because the
inflow is and the outflow are the same
thing as the state flow we're learning
we can just force that the state flow
equals the reward at Terminal States so
this is like a boundary condition that
we reinforce in addition to this
detailed balance objective which has to
be satisfied on every Edge inside the
graph and um from the algebra on the
previous slide we can see that if the
detailed balance
constraint holds on every
Edge then the edge flow that we recover
from it by writing the edge flow as
state flow times
policy satisfies flow matching so by the
first main theorem about gonets the
policy is sampling proportionately to
the
reward
now this parameterization involves no
Edge flows it involves two policies and
estate
flow um we can reduce the number of
objects involved by fixing the backward
policy to some simple distribution of
our choice I just want to note this here
and I'll come back to this a little
later okay so we have detailed balance
and it solves the problem of summing
over a large number of parents because
it depends only on a single edge but
it's still local and so it still has the
credit assignment problem that I
discussed a few slides ago so it would
be nice if we instead had a trajectory
level objective that is one that sees a
reward from a terminal State and
immediately sends a gradient update to
all of the edges seen along the
trajectory and
um when um and we struggled with that
for a long time to find such an
objective we first came up with it in
the case of a tree-shaped graph where
states only have one parent and then
eventually we had this realization that
um we can get a simple trajectory level
objective which I'll derive for you
now so now comes now comes the the maist
slide of the presentation so I promise
it's only downhill from there or uphill
depending on how you see
it so let's look at a
trajectory so it starts at the initial
State as zero and it takes M steps ends
at a state SN which I also call x x is
usually a terminal State and let's write
the detail balance constraint on each
Edge and I write in this way in the same
form that it appears in the loss
so f * PF equals f f * PB so I write
that the quotient equals one for all of
those transitions and SN is a terminal
state so the flow at the terminal State
equals the reward R events all of those
equal one
now let's take all of these constraints
and let's multiply them together so
they're all equal to one so their
product equals
one um so I've done nothing here just
multiplied all the equalities in the
first line now a lot of cancellation is
going to happen because the flow in the
denominator of one term cancels with the
flow in the numerator of the next term
so all the flows cancel except the very
first F of a zero in the very last R ofx
and we're left with
this so I've just done some
rearrangement of
terms so let's look at this so in the
numerator we have the flow at
s0o and then the product of all of the
policies transition probabilities along
the trajectory from s0 all the way to SN
and the in the denominator we have the
reward and then the product of backward
transition probabilities as we uh start
from X and then we go backward along
this
trajectory and no other state flows
survived now that's pretty
nice so we have this uh so-called
trajectory balance constraint which says
that this numerator and this denominator
ER are equal now I can also write it in
this condensed form so flow as zero
times a forward likelihood of that whole
trajectory PF of to just means the
product of those transition
probabilities in the numerator equals
the reward times the product of all the
backward transitions in the
denominator now I write PB of to given X
because the backward probability of a
trajectory only makes sense if I know
where to start that backward trajectory
at a terminal at a given terminal State
X so when we have some constraint in
Chets we want to turn into a
loss let's do that we for a trajectory
we just enforce with the same kind of
squared log ratio trick we enforce that
these two quantities are equal so the
log of um initial State flow times
forward policy forward likelihood of the
trajectory divided by reward times
backward likehood of the trajectory
squared we're supposed to minimize
that so this objective is trajectory
level so we it depends on all of the
Transitions and their forward and
backward
probabilities so when we see a
trajectory and we get a reward we
immediately get an update to all of this
all of the transitions that we had in
the trajectory so it's a global
objective now there's a there's a
theorem and it's not exactly obvious
that why it holds that if we make this
objective hold so if we make F PF equals
R time PB for every trajectory this is
sufficient for the forward policy to
sample proportionately to the reward so
the derivation I showed shows it's
necessary because from detailed balance
through this cancellation we get
trajectory balance but the other way
requires requires some requires doing
some
meth
so practically what do we do we sample a
trajectory from from our policy or from
some more exploratory version you'll
hear about that in the next talk and we
perform gradient updates on this uh TB
TBC let's take a closer look at what
properties it has now I've already said
this is a global objective so it leasts
to faster credit assignment due to um
yielding a gradient update to every
state along a trajectory when a reward
is received in addition it doesn't
require learning the state flow for
every state and for for every state only
for the initial State F ofs zero
everything else canceled in our
derivation and just like like uel
mentioned before the F ofs Zer which we
do have to learn at convergence ends up
being equal to the total reward so the
sum of all rewards of terminal States we
we use the letter Z to denote that
often now here's a point which um which
is very important in understanding
gonets as a variational inference
algorithm um the TB loss is actually
doing
something something with a a deeper
meaning so it's equating or trying to
make equal two distributions Not Over
States but over trajectories
one of them is the distribution over
trajectories that you sample by starting
at the initial State and then sampling
the forward
policy the other one is the one that you
sample by taking a terminal State
sampled from the true reward
distribution now we can't usually do
that as want to learn and then following
the backward policy from that state back
to the initial State as
zero um the trajectory balance objective
is trying to make those two
distributions over trajectories equal by
making the ratio of likelihoods equal to
one so one consideration that falls out
of that is that we can actually fix the
backward policy so given a terminal
State we can just decide once and for
all from the beginning without having it
learned what what is the posterior
distribution over trajectories that will
get us to that
state we we can for example make the
backward policy uniform so that's a
common choice because it often
simplifies it reduces the number of
models we have to learn
um when when when I'm just starting to
prototype a Chinet I often just start
with the trajectory balance with the
uniform background policy because it's
very
simple um if we fix the backward policy
at every state to be uniform over the
parents then the only things we have to
learn are the initial initial State flow
and the forward policy very simple right
so just like in reinfor learning where
we just learn a policy or maybe
sometimes a value function except we
just have to learn one extra thing which
is the initial State
FL and a practical consideration is that
this initial State flow we often learn
in the log domain and it often helps to
set a Higher Learning rate on that
because it can be trained stably even
with a high um even with a large
updates so just some results um as as as
we saw trajectory balance
allows you to find more modes and
converge faster generally than other
training
objectives on a bit sequence task here's
a molecule domain where we first
implemented and tested trajectory
balance so we get more stable training
more um modes discovered and so higher
diversity and higher reward of the
typically generated
objects now I want to conclude with some
um practical considerations about how to
choose an
objective so you're you want to train a
J net for your problem you decided what
objects you want to generate you
designed the state and action space so
you decided the generative process that
you're going to use so what objective
should you use well so I think that
trajectory balance is a good objective
to try by default because um it's fairly
simple to implement and it yields a fast
graded assignment on the other hand it
has some limit which are that it can
have a high gradient variance and a high
memory cost especially if the
trajectories are very long or there's a
very high range of rewards that you
encounter
so sometimes you might want to try
something based on Flow matching or
detail balance
instead now in general detail balance
does not work as well in in in settings
that we often encounter um unless some
special con straints are satisfied um
there's um there's a trick called the
forward-looking flow parameterization in
which if you can compute some kind of
proxy reward at not complete States at
incomplete States intermediate States
then you can parameterize the log flow
function not directly through a neural
network but as an additive correction to
this proxy log
reward and if there's interest I can
give a few examples of that in the
questions there are similar tricks
positive possible if from every state is
allowed to terminate which is the case
in some generative
problems and
um there we can also
learn the flow function as a correction
to the reward of that object if we chose
to terminate
there and there's another objective
called sub trajectory balance which I
won't go into but which is a kind of
interpolation between detailed balance
and trajectory balance so trajectory
balance learns from an entire trajectory
by multiplying together the detailed
balance constraints and then canceling
all the state flows detail balance
learns from a single edge so sub
trajectory balance U does this but takes
a partial trajectory starting not
necessarily at s0o ending not
necessarily at a terminal State and
performs this cancellation so that only
the state flow at the start of the sub
trajectory and at the end are remaining
and um combining the detail
balance Edge level trajectory balance um
B trajectory level and sub trajectory
balance for partial pieces in the
appropriate way can give us the best of
both worlds in terms of stable training
with the low gradient variance coming
from detailed balance and a fast credit
assignment that comes from trajectory
level
objectives so I'll will finish with that
and here are the main references for the
losses and ideas I've
discussed and you can check out um any
of those if you're interested thank
you we're a little behind schedule but
we have five minutes for
questions hi yeah thank you for the nice
presentation I I have a question about
the how to choose like how to get
samples so I remember that like the in
the training process uh ml mentions that
the policy could be off policy but in
practice like which policy we should
choose um that that's a good question so
so we know that for the forward policy
to sample proportionally to the reward
trajectory balance or detail balance or
flow matching has to be satisfied at
every state or at every Edge or at every
trajectory so we are actually free to
choose any training policy we like as
long as it has full
support um now what we do in practice
this is the subject of the next
presentation but just to give you a
preview um common techniques are some
modification to the on policy training
like introducing random actions or
tempering as well as using information
about known terminal states such as
those obtained through uh replay buffer
so if we have interesting uh terminal
States we can train on backward
trajectory sampled from them but you'll
hear more in the next talk thank you uh
can I ask another question like how can
we choose the length of sub trajectory
in practice as well um for sub
trajectory balance yeah um well that's
an interesting question I don't know the
best answer but what we did in the paper
on sub trajectory of balance is we took
all of the sub
trajectories and we weighted them in
proportion to some constant Lambda to
the power of the length which is um
inspired by a technique called TD Lambda
in reinforcement
learning okay thank
you considering the trajectory balance
objective you said that sometimes common
practice is to set a backwards policy to
a uniform I have a hard time
understanding how this wouldn't like
just enforce the forward policy to also
be uniform like does how does this
actually let us still sample
proportional to the
reward well first the theoretical side
of that answer is that for any backward
policy you choose there's a unique
forward policy such that together they
optimize the trajectory balance
objective um now how do we understand
that
so we think of TB as equating to
distributions over trajectories so let's
start with the this backward
distribution we can sample it by taking
a terminal state from the reward
distribution which imagine Oracle can
sample for you and then sampling uniform
back
policy so that distribution over
trajectories can also be sampled
forward and if those two distributions
are equal then their marginal
distributions over the terminal state
are also the same and for the backward
one by construction it's the reward
distribution but for the forward one it
has to be the same oh I see thank you
and um I suggest you can read the paper
on JL Nets and variational inference for
a discussion of this
thanks for the talk uh I guess my
question is what if you cannot uh en
numerate parents like if it's just too
difficult because even for the backwards
policy I guess you have to know how many
you
have uh yes that's so the question the
question as I understand it is even if
you're fixing the backward policy to
uniform so one over number of
parents you still need to know how many
parents there
are and um
now if you have never gotten your hands
dirty with jlon Nets it might not make
sense why that can even be a problem but
in fact it can be for example in
molecule generation when there are many
ways to remove a component from a
molecule you may get possible parents
which are equal due to isomorphism so
there are different um different
construction orders of the same molecule
uh and it's a difficult graph
isomorphism check to determine if two
ways of expression the same molecule are
actually the same
so well there's nothing you can do about
that you have to do isomorphism check on
the parents I don't have a better
answer okay you can do faster
isomorphism checks if you learn um if
you have a learned hasher embedding for
the parents which allows you to quickly
determine if two um two molecules are
isomorphic
but yeah that that could arise in other
settings where hatching a graph is not
is not necessarily the answer uh it
could be also in domain uncertainty of
uh but anyway so I guess the answer is
you can't you have to you have to find a
way to any Mar the
parents